bonsoir voci des titres de l'actualité
de ce mardi 3 octobre le cessez-le-feu
n'a pas tenu entre israéliens et
palestiniens de nouveau des morts et des
blessés
yasser arafat ehud barak seront demain à
paris pour tenter de renouer un dialogue
très très difficile invités de ce
journal leila shahid déléguée générale
de l'autorité palestinienne en france la
ministre martine aubry veut réécrire la
nouvelle convention sur l'assurance
chômage plusieurs points de désaccord
persistent entre cfdt et medef d'une
part et le gouvernement de l'autre
comment créer une épargne salariale
française le projet de laurent fabius en
discussion au sein de la gauche
la modification de la loi sur la
contraception et l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse présenté demain
en conseil des ministres un document
dans ce journal
nous avons accompagné une femme
subissant une ivg à la fin de cette
édition le bonheur de retrouver michel
jonasz son concert à l'olympia avec un
nouvel album paul ouest ce matin à
l'aube israéliens palestiniens décident
est un cessez-le-feu de part et d'autre
il ne fut pas respecté des hélicoptères
israéliens ont tiré des roquettes
et malgré le retrait de certaines de ses
positions en cisjordanie par l'armée
israélienne des palestiniens ont
poursuivi leurs attaques il ya de
nouveau beaucoup de morts et de blessés
les violences et les images de guerre
n'ont pas disparu après l'annonce d'une
tentative de nouvelles négociations à
paris demain commentaires claude samper
le fragile cessez le feu n'aura duré que
quelques heures
cet après midi de très violents
affrontements ente à nouveau embrasé la
cisjordanie et gaza
à naplouse par exemple une fusillade a
opposé pendant plusieurs heures
manifestants palestiniens et soldats
israéliens
une fusillade qui a éclaté après les
obsèques d'un jeune palestinien tué hier
mêmes scènes de guerre dans la bande de
gaza près de la colonie de peuplement
juive de netzarim les jeunes
palestiniens ont assiégé pendant
plusieurs heures les positions
israéliennes
les hélicoptères de tsahal l'armée
israélienne ont à plusieurs reprises de
lancer des roquettes et mitrailler les
assaillants
quatre palestiniens ont trouvé la mort
quatre décès qui porte à 60 le nombre de
victimes de ces cinq derniers jours
ce matin pourtant un calme précaire
régnait dans les territoire autonome un
accord de cessez le feu avait
apparemment été obtenu dans la nuit
entre israéliens et palestiniens dans
certains secteurs comme ici à ramallah
l'armée israélienne s'est même replié
ici les soldats abandonnent leurs
positions dans un hôtel qui avait été
réquisitionné dans la bande de gaza ce
matin plusieurs familles palestiniennes
ont profité de ces quelques heures de
répit pour mettre à l'abri leurs biens
personnels
mais dès cet après midi les
affrontements ont repris à bethléem des
manifestants très jeunes se sont opposés
aux soldats israéliens
chacun luttant avec ses moyens mêmes
scènes de guérilla urbaine à hébron ce
soir les palestiniens dénoncent toujours
l'usagé disproportionné de la force par
israël et les israéliens accusent
toujours yasser arafat d'avoir orchestré
ces affrontements alors on mesurera la
tension entre palestiniens et israéliens
à l'aune de l'exaspération des arabes
israéliens ils sont un million cinq cent
mille soit près de 17% de la population
en israël
alan chalvron et gilles jacquet sont
allés à leur rencontre à nazareth et
ivey nouvelles scènes de violence
cette scène tournée par un vidéaste
amateur bouleverse déjà israël car ce ne
sont pas seulement des femmes que ces
policiers israéliens passent à tabac
mais des israéliennes des femmes
israéliennes
la scène se passait à nazareth en
galilée à l'issue de l'enterrement d'un
des huit arabes israéliens tués hier un
jeune homme de 26 ans et ya de la
huacana les slogans étaient religieux
mais aussi politique par notre sang et
notre âme nous nous sacrifierons pour
toi al aqsa la mosquée sainte de
jérusalem
les funérailles se sont terminées par
quelques incidents mais rien à voir avec
la flambée de violences d'hier la petite
ville de taybé à une trentaine de
kilomètres de tel aviv et est
aujourd'hui encore sous le choc
désertée au milieu des restes des
affrontements de la veille
les habitants de pib sont tous arabes et
israéliens mais quand on leur demande ce
qu'ils sont les réponses fusent
palestinien arabe et musulmane vivant en
israël
je suis un arabe israélien mais les
israéliens ne nous parle pas comme des
juifs et nous considère comme des
palestiniens
il sentit que nous soyons du même sens
de la même religion du même peuple que
nos frères qui je la bats tous les jours
rien ne sera plus comme avant pour les
habitants tel paix et pour tous les
arabes d'israël
la nuit dernière le premier ministre
israélien ehud barak espérait que le
cessez-le-feu met fin aux affrontements
il n'en fut donc rien l'inquiétude des
dirigeants israéliens très vives
d'autant qu'ils sont pressés par les
colons reportage de notre correspondant
permanent charles enderlin les analyses
présentées au gouvernement israélien
sont plutôt pessimistes
un général a même déclaré que le pire
était peut-être à venir
les premiers concernés sont les
habitants des implantations juives en
cisjordanie et à gaza ils sont en état
de siège
nous sommes dans la ligne de mire des
tireurs d'élite palestiniens ce soit
dans nos bureaux dans le jardin
d'enfants et le pire aussi dans nos
crèches nous demandons que les
dirigeants israéliens au lieu de faire
toujours ce processus diabolique de fer
concession sur concession pour ramener
le calme pour amener les palestiniens
terminé gociations leur explique qu'il
faut une position israélienne très ferme
et que les patients doivent arrêter ce
recours à la violence à la place d'un
processus de négociations pour shimon
peres l'ancien premier ministre
il n'y a pas le choix le processus de
paix doit continuer ça va continuer
malgré tous les problèmes marguet malgré
les tragédies d'aujourd'hui parce qu'el
nino il n'est pas le signal nous n'avons
pas emprunté ce soir les efforts de paix
ce poursuivre le ministre des affaires
étrangères par intérim et lui optimiste
une situation plus stable je pense que
c'est ce qui c'est la plate forme
nécessaire pour avancer dans le
processus dans une situation de violence
ça n'aide pas à concentrer les énergies
dans nos objectifs et à la veille du
sommet de paris monsieur ben ami a
rencontré miguel moratinos l'émissaire
européen au proche orient
pendant ce temps ariel sharon qui est
accusé par les palestiniens les états
unis et l'europe d'être à l'origine de
cette vague de violence monsieur sharon
multiplie les interviews sur les chiens
ni ce raid pour expliquer que sa visite
sur l'esplanade des mosquées n'a pas mis
le feu aux poudres
en fait dit il le responsable de tout
cela
arafat qui a fomenté les émeutes alors
demain et oudin qui a ses rafales seront
à paris charles enderlin
qu'attend-t-on qu'espère ton de cette
journée en israël vient tout d'abord
peut-être une consolidation du
cessez-le-feu
il faut dire qu'un abîme de méfiance et
par ehud barak et yasser arafat
les deux hommes n'ont pas de véritables
relations personnelles comme c'était le
cas entre itzhak rabin et yasser arafat
par exemple il faudrait que les deux
hommes parviennent au moins à 100 ans
or les américains ont préféré ne pas
prendre de risques demain d'après ce que
l'on sait il n'y aura pas de rencontre
barack arafat mais séparément
madame albright rencontrera yasser
arafat puis ehud barak
et puis monsieur clinton a préféré ne
pas faire le déplacement
il craint tron un nouvel échec après le
fiasco du sommet de camp david en
juillet dernier donc tout le monde
avance prudemment le sommet d'après
demain à sharm el cheikh dans le sinaï
en egypte sera peut-être plus utile au
moins la continuation de ce qui se
passera à paris demain
merci chers les vous évoqué hier charles
la régionalisation de la crise
aujourd'hui on en a constaté la réalité
avec de fortes manifestations au liban
d'une part et puis à bagdad en irak
d'autre part des dizaines de milliers de
personnes ont défilé en prononçant les
slogans hostiles à israël mais il a
jailli de bonsoir il ya quelques
instants kofi annan dit que nous sommes
au bord de la guerre totale alors à quoi
pourra bien servir demain à paris la
venue de yasser arafat et d'ehud barak
se mettre fin à la guerre
vous croyez je crois que nous avons
derrière non quand même cette année d'un
processus qui a été difficile long long
qui a coûté la vie à la mine qui a vu
passer trois premiers sites israéliens
nous avons déjà une partie des sujets
qui ont été négociées ce serait vraiment
tragique qu'on jette tout ça à la
poubelle parce que depuis l'entrée de
monsieur sharon sur l'esplanade des
mosquées
il y a pratiquement une guerre que mène
l'armée israélienne contre des
manifestants palestiniens avec des
pierres mais en même temps vous vous ne
maîtrisez pas tout le peuple palestinien
il ya des extrémistes aussi palestiniens
ils y apprennent à la masse qui a
intérêt à en rajouter non je ne pense
pas du tout que ce soit des
manifestations du hamas sont vous avez
vu les images
depuis maintenant six jours il y a une
armée qui est une des plus puissantes du
monde qui est la quatrième du monde la
première du moyen orient qui utilisent
des balles réelles
on a vu des roquettes lancées par des
hélicoptères des chars et blindés contre
une population civile qui jettent des
pierres populations civiles qui vit sous
l'occupation depuis 33 ans
cinquième à la police brésilienne des
heures - oui mais incomparable aux armes
de l'armée israélienne en plus elle
manifeste parce qu'elle est occupé parce
qu'elle est dans un territoire que
toutes les résolutions de la coupe
nationale exige d'être évacués que les
accords d'oslo demande à israël
d'évacuer depuis sept ans nous sommes
très en retard les palestiniens
attendaient un état le 13 septembre 2000
il y à peine deux semaines se fut aux
joueurs d'avoir un état ils ont
messieurs charolles qui viennent les
défier et l'armée israélienne qui
recommence la même relation qu'elle a
eue pendant les pires moments de la
différence entre ehud barak il ya ces
rafales
on ne se parle pas on ne se voit pas je
vous seriez surpris de savoir que l'avs
de ces événements ils dînaient ensemble
chez monsieur bah la semaine dernière la
semaine dernière je me suis forgé
monsieur barak c'est vous dire que
lorsque vous êtes dans une situation où
nous avons l'impression que monsieur
barack un double langage avec monsieur
arafat il parle de négociations de
dialogue et avec la population
palestinienne
il emploie les moyens les plus forts je
dirais les plus barbares mais peut-être
qu'il est précieux dans ces extraits
milan si je crois qu'il est avant tout
il est le résultat d'un esprit colonial
qui est de dire aux palestiniens ou bien
vous acceptez mes conditions de la paix
comme moi je la conçois
ou bien je vaux casse savez ce n'est pas
la première fois qu'une puissance
occupante essaye de briser une
résistance ce que le conte plein pas les
militaires c'est que cette méthode ne
fait que rajouter à la force des
résistants mais en quoi comment peut-on
croire que le processus de pub peut
encore être valable puisque je crois que
le système de coordination n'est pas de
ne sont plus il ya plus que la troupe
commune de rénovation joint je n'ai pas
dit que c'était faisable
j'ai dit que ça vaut la peine d'essayer
parce que je crois que demain nous
n'allons pas discuter des négociations
de paix vous demain sur lui à mettre un
nom de lieu à chambéry ce bluff
si monsieur barack demain répond aux
trois conditions que le président à la
famille pour reprendre les négociations
ces trois conditions sont les suivants
que l'armée cesse de tirer sur les
palestiniens quel sous le tir des zones
autonomes et de cela des mosquées et
troisièmement qu'une enquête
internationale sous l'égide des états
unis et de l'europe
div qui a été responsable il y a quand
même 60 mans et au moins 2000 blessés et
en contre quelqu'un réponde en
contrepartie vous vous veut croire non
les négociations et nous essayons de
faire une paix que je pense la majorité
des italiens souhaitent et qu'en tout
cas la majorité palestiniens souhaitent
je vois que c'est la dernière tentative
et je crois que c'est pour cela commandé
le bret a répondu à la demande du
président clinton que le président
chirac
accueil à paris cette réunion parce que
si de même n'arrivons pas à allaiter ce
massacre et à reprendre peut-être
appeler demain ou le jour d'après les
négociations ils étaient dix ans que la
guerre qui reviendra ne sera pas
seulement réservé aux palestiniens
vous avez vous même montré les images
des baisses de barda des pierres c'est
quoi c'est la guerre où c'est la
bataille pour jérusalem à savoir est ce
que c'est c'est là le noeud du problème
est ce qu'au fond la proposition qu'a
évoquée monsieur baratte à savoir que
il y aurait al-qods et jérusalem ça
pourrait savez ce que ça c'est le texte
à part vous non je crois que c'est tout
je crois que ce qui s'est passé c'est
avant tout une manipulation criminel de
la part de monsieur sharon de politique
intérieure comme l'a dit d'heure le
président chirac dans un contexte où les
sentiments étaient à fleur de peau parce
que les palestiniens attendent depuis
sept ans clapet devienne une réalité
d'israël est aussi l'at on rigole ils
ont grossi mais il n'est pas symétrique
il y à un état constitué avec un
gouvernement
les citoyens israéliens sont à la plage
depuis rosh hashana depuis le nouvel an
nous sommes dans des bicoques comme vous
les avez vus devant des tanks sans moyen
de survivre sans frontières sans
gouvernement sans état
c'est l'apathie mettrie entre les
palestiens livre un lien et donc il ya
une colère il y a même une colère contre
l'autorité palestinienne
la population demande à la fois des
résultats elle veut plus des promesses
de paix elle veut une vraie paix elle
veut de l'emploi elle veut des droits
sociaux des droits à l'éducation
elle veut avoir la dignité d'exister
comme les israéliens et je crois que
c'est ça qui explique la colère s'est
pas seulement
l'incident les responsabilités de
monsieur charolles a déclenché mais la
responsabilité de monsieur barack de
choisir les moyens d'affronter la colère
des palestiniens et honore demain on
essaiera de comprendre pourquoi
et si on arrive à voir ce que nous
demandons à monsieur ballack qui est
responsable en tant que ministre de la
défense ou pour la peut-être les plans
des négociations après demain merci
alors en algérie la nuit dernière toute
une famille a été massacrée près de
khemis miliana c'est à 120 km à l'ouest
d'alger 14 personnes d'une même famille
ont été tués un groupe d'islamistes
armés serait l'auteur de ce massacre par
ailleurs 7 personnes ont également été
assassinés à benchikha où ces prêts de
la province de médias ce matin en serbie
malgré les menaces de milosevic et un
début de répression contre les grévistes
la désobéissance civile au pouvoir ça
grandit
certains policiers auraient même
fraterniser avec les manifestants
la grève des mineurs de coupe barras a
entraîné des coupures d'électricité
malgré une intervention du chef d'état
major de l'armée yougoslave commentaires
gérard risbec avec alexandra et beach à
belgrade
épuisé mais déterminée depuis quatre
jours et quatre nuits ils sont en grève
politique des mineurs qui ne réclament
des augmentations de salaires ni
amélioration de leurs conditions de
travail
ils ne veulent qu'une seule chose que
slobodan milosevic s'en aille
la nuit a été d'autant plus longue
qu'ils ont eu un invité surprise le chef
d'état major de l'armée le général
pavkovic la discussion a été animée à la
durée 3 heures le général a menacé
d'instaurer l'état d'urgence car la
grève menacerait le bon fonctionnement
de l'armée les mineurs n'ont pas changé
d'avis on a répondu au général qu'est ce
que c'est que cette armée qui ne peut
plus fonctionner après quatre jours de
grève la mine de kolubara fournit 60% du
charbon de la serbie elle alimente les
principales centrales thermiques de la
région de belgrade
alors bien sûr des coupures
d'électricité ont commencé une grande
partie du centre de niche la troisième
ville du pays est plongé dans le noir
ça fait plus de dix ans que l'on vit
dans le noir alors passé quatre ou cinq
jours de plus sans électricité et ne
permettra peut-être de nous en sortir
je ne peux pas parler trop longtemps je
n'ai pas dormi depuis vendredi je suis
fatigué je vous demande de rester avec
nous en plus grand nombre pour nous
apporter votre soutien au soir les 7500
employés de la mine poursuivre leur
grève les gueules noires disent qu'ils
iront jusqu'au bout pour milosevic les
trahisons se succèdent l'opposition
aurait reçu une disquette informatique
des résultats électoraux confirmant sa
victoire disque est venu du ciel si
j'ose dire plus exactement jeté d'une
fenêtre d'un bâtiment officiel à
belgrade il fut question de la serbie et
de l'aide que l'europe souhaitait
apporter au peuple serbe face à
milosevic lors des cérémonies de dresde
en allemagne aujourd'hui c'est dans
cette ville que l'on célébrait les dix
ans jour pour jour de la réunification
allemande
elle nous colle absents jacques chirac
lui a rendu ostensiblement hommage le
président français a également évoqué
avec madeleine albright la situation au
proche orient et les rencontres de
demain à paris avec yasser arafat
ehud barak dix ans donc que l'allemagne
ne fait plus qu'une à l'est ces années
ont été nécessaires pour changer les
habitudes et un état d'esprit c'est
flagrant dans l'école où patrice
condamné mickaël à verte se sont rendus
c'est un macho au nord-est de l'ex
allemagne de l'est
surtout ne pas se fier à la quiétude des
lieux la région est rude le chômage
frappe une personne sur cinq les jeunes
couples préfèrent plier bagage et si les
effectifs de l'école primaire ne cesse
d'augmenter
c'est tout simplement parce que dans les
villages alentour les écoles on les
affaires ils ont l'âge de la
réunification tout au plus on aura prend
plus le fonctionnement d'un col cause on
ne recule que plus les bienfaits du
communisme et ils ne verront pas
débarquer à l'improviste l'inspecteur
chargé de vérifier que les enseignants
respecte la ligne politique imposée par
le pouvoir pour les institutrices déjà
en place avant 1990 réunification
implique responsabilisation
je travaille de manière plus créative du
tonnerre maintenant pour moi le travail
représente un espace de liberté nous
écoute et des pays frères ont fait de
l'eau des paysages et nous les
enseignantes
on a vécu les idées aux rennais - la
première en solo je ne vais pas aux gens
j'ai beaucoup saigné la musique je
faisait chanter aux enfants oh oui mais
elle est la doyenne des candidats même
si le biais de filiales et le rythme
sans fin mais franchement le débat ira
chanter les choses comme ça
elle sait de quoi elle parle la
directrice elle fut elle-même élèves
dans cette école
aujourd'hui elle estime que les
programmes et les structures scolaires
importé de l'ouest ont transformé les
gamins ce n'était pas les samériens ou
encore je ne sais pas voilà ce que les
cours quand on le questionne sur la
réunification la rb à la rfa si
d'aventuré une belle en savoir plus il
leur suffit de traverser la rue face à
l'école un bâtiment abrite le musée de
la rda
à l'intérieur une exposition degré
obsolète et pour le visiteur le plaisir
plutôt réconfortant de se dire qu'il est
bien dans un musée est pas à la maison
retour au parlement pour les députés
français premier débat d'actualité cet
après midi avec des questions de
politique étrangère et de gestion
sociale et comme une impression de calme
après les polémiques de la semaine
dernière née des révélations de jean
claude méry sur les affaires des hlm de
la mairie de paris au palais bourbon
compte rendu jean baptiste près dali et
christian hottin
une sorte d'armistice ou de perm et pour
cause d'affaires en cours la rentrée
parlementaire promettait pourtant d'être
explosive mais chaque camp avait décidé
de ne pas parler de ce qui fâche dans
les couloirs il ya bien des attaques
le parti socialiste mais même en cause
jacques chirac mais il s'agit de
critiques politiques
moi j'écoute jacques chirac lorsqu'il se
déplace en province ou lorsqu'il
commente l'action du gouvernement
ils sortent sur les mécontentements il
dit tout et son contraire ça c'est pas
une politique dans l'hémicycle pas de
déchaînements au contraire une seule
question plutôt allusive sur l' affaire
strauss kahn
c'est tout den sérénité fait grincer
quelques dents à la tente que la
pression n'était pas évident à ce que la
tradition de la démocratie parlementaire
c'est de se dire les choses à
l'assemblée nationale n'est pas à
travers les journaux dans la rue sans
dit long sur la l'ampleur de
l'hypocrisie de notre personnel
politique qui avant la reprise de la
session cris lancent des cris d'orfraie
crient au scandale réclame transparence
et vérité
et lorsqu'il s'agit dans des bacs devant
la danse qui est le coeur de la
république c'est-à-dire l'assemblée
nationale
tout le monde se tait les verts
promettent une question sur la
responsabilité pénale du chef de l'état
ce sera la semaine prochaine au rpr on a
décrété que les attaques politiciennes
ne doivent pas être la règle à
l'assemblée et on s'est fait très
discret aujourd'hui
bref une journée sans polémique avec un
mot tabou celui d'affaires certains
ministres m'ont même plaisanté
c'est jean françois mattei qui devient
le président du groupe démocratie
libérale l'assemblée nationale il
succède à josé rossi josé rossi qui
comme françois léotard a applaudi le
premier ministre lionel jospin ce qui
n'a pas fait plaisir à ses amis à droite
le premier ministre évoquait en réponse
à une question d'un député udf la
possibilité d'une modification de
détention de certains détenus condamnés
corses en revanche pas question de
regrouper l'ensemble des condamnés à la
prison de borgo près de bastia
ce sont des propositions partielle et
insuffisante déclare ce soir de
nationaliste corse jean guy talamoni
pour la deuxième fois la ministre de
l'emploi martine aubry n'a pas accepté
la convention d'assurance-chômage
rédigée et approuvée par le medef la
cfdt la cftc et la cgc madame aubry met
en cause l'absence réelle de financement
et les sanctions prévues pour contrainte
des chômeurs à accepter des emplois qui
ne correspondent pas à leurs
qualifications cette interprétation est
récusé par nikon aux tailles par le
medef
la ministre a donc commencé une nouvelle
série de discussions une explication et
jean bernard schmidt et claude barny
martine aubry plutôt satisfaite du tour
qu'elle a joué aux signataires de la
convention unedic pour entamé ses
consultations ce matin et là comme par
hasard invités les plus farouches
adversaires du projet de réforme la cgt
et force ouvrière et cet après midi à
l'assemblée
elle passe à l'offensive pas question
d'agréer l'accord unedic
ce n'est pas parce que les partenaires
sociaux ont souhaité modifier la loi
c'est parce qu'ils ont souhaité modifier
la loi dans un sens qui veut contraindre
les chômeurs et qui ne veut pas les
accompagner que le gouvernement est
légitime a donné son avis sur l'accord
tel qu'il a été signé
la ministre n'est pas avare de critiques
selon elle il faudra radier quatre cent
mille chômeurs pour faire des économies
faux répond la cfdt avec ce système les
chômeurs retrouveront plus rapidement un
emploi
autre inquiétude de martine aubry menacé
de sanctions les chômeurs devront
accepter n'importe quel poste
encore faut la cfdt réplique on
appréciera la valeur professionnelle
d'un travailleur suivant sa formation
son expérience et ses responsabilités
dernier rebondissement du jour une
partie du patronat refuse désormais de
discussion
on a suffisamment discuté ensuite ils
ont rencontré suffisamment négocier
maintenant ça suffit il faut que l'on
s'en réfère aux poses instances de
l'état et il n'est pas question que les
énarques supplantent les paritaire
martine aubry entend quand même
rencontrer les autres partenaires cette
semaine pour trouver une solution elle
doit faire vite son départ du ministère
est prévue le 18 octobre prochain
et la tâche de martine aubry sera bien
différente demain
elle présentera en effet en conseil des
ministres un texte de loi visant à
actualiser de la législation sur la
contraception et l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse de loi conquise
par les femmes près de longues luttes en
1967 et 1975
le projet prévoit l'allongement du délai
maximum requis pour obtenir une ivg de
10 à 12 semaines de grossesse
laetitia legendre et valérie guiton ont
accompagné la démarche d'une jeune femme
et de son compagnon qui ont fait le
choix d'une ivg dans un centre
hospitalier à saint-denis demandes sont
nombreuses dans cet hôpital a consulté
le médecin du planning pour interrompre
leur grossesse
cet entretien doit permettre aux
professionnels de comprendre les
difficultés de ces femmes pour mieux les
accompagner dans leurs choix
après les entretiens avec le médecin
avec l'assistante sociale et la semaine
de réflexion 10 à thouars l'opération
peut enfin avoir lieu ce matin-là deux
femmes viennent pour une ivg
l'une d'entre elle sarah n'a que 20 ans
et déjà un petit garçon elle n'a pas
encore terminé ses études
cette grossesse elle n'a pas les moyens
de la mener à terme comme mes enfants je
n'aurais pas manquer fait d'un deuxième
enfant elle ferait un petit peu
difficile ircom mon copain de travail
pas un petit peu trop difficile un choix
qu'elle était difficile à faire
l'intervention ne prend que quelques
minutes un moment de solitude d'angoise
de souffrance et soufflé tout doucement
doucement
une éternité voilà votre collait
parfaitement ouvert donc le médicament
avait en effet à la fin de l'opération
le médecin lui pose à sa demande un
stérilet se fait pour accompagner ce
arabe qui va rester encore une heure à
l'hôpital toute une équipe de
professionnels des femmes psychologues
médecins ou penser hier conjugale
position qui vous le sentez le mieux
cela comme ça comme ça c'est mieux lotis
c'était très difficile et douloureux
pour
pourquoi pardon enlever un enfant mon
corps et ça c'est un petit peu
douloureux et ça fait travailler un peu
l'esprit léger ça fait mal comment vous
sentez vous jacques est à seulement vide
à ses côtés son compagnon venu pour les
soutenir
reymi42 coup le faire donc on a deux
aussi dans quelques semaines nous montre
que c'est pas facile comme ça sur le dos
aux médecins qui pratiquent des ivg
depuis des années cette intervention
reste un acte chirurgical ni tabou ni
dévalorisant pour les femmes ça a
toujours fait partie de leur vie elles
ont toujours parlé elles ont toujours
fait quelles que soient les époques
alors c'était plus ou moins permissifs
en compte tenu de l'histoire mais ce
n'est pas un acte thabo pour les femmes
c'est un acte tabou pour les politiques
les politiques
l'équipe du planning attend le réforme
avec impatience dans ce service près de
800 ivg sont pratiquées chaque année
très souvent sur des femmes sans
ressources des mineurs ou des étrangères
dont les papiers ne sont pas toujours en
règle
chaque jour elles doivent composer avec
ce qu'elle considère comme les
insuffisances de la loi veil tout en
assumant la détresse des fins
présentation aux députés par laurent
fabius ce soit un projet de loi sur
l'épargné salariale il s'agit d'ouvrir
cette épargne aux salariés des petites
et moyennes entreprises le texte est
loin de faire l'unanimité à gauche comme
à droite
explications et peggy leroy nathalie
gallet la bourse un milieu réservé aux
accros du cac 40 aux spécialistes des
placements plus aujourd'hui avec le plan
d'epargne salariale volontaire même ses
ouvriers spécialisés pourront placer une
partie de leur salaire en bourse quand
le salarié versera 1 franc l'employeur
pourra rajouter jusqu'à 3 francs une
épargne volontaire et individuelle
investi en bourse notamment en actions
de l'entreprise
le plan d'épargné est bloquée pendant
dix ans ensuite le salarié
pères son argent et ses plus values sous
forme de capital uniquement la rente
sera probablement abandonner trop proche
des fonds de pension selon la gauche
mais salarié ne pourra consacrer qu'un
quart de ses revenus au plan d'epargne
salariale
une façon de protéger le système de
retraite par répartition pour les
libéraux toutes ces précautions dénature
le projet ce n'est pas un projet all
loyal qui explique une nouvelle
philosophie car en fait je crois qu il y
à bien une conversion de la majorité
d'aujourd'hui au système des fonds de
pension les versements des employeurs
seront également plafonné trente mille
francs au maximum taxées à partir de 15
mille francs question que va ça l'état
de ces nouveaux revenus fiscaux pour une
partie de la majorité
la réponse doit venir des salariés
eux-mêmes et pour que les salariés
puissent donner leur avis est entendu
que cet argent leur appartient et on ne
pourrait pas accepter que d'autres
décident de la destination de ces fonds
sans que ceux ci aient leur mot à dire
pour l'instant ce sont les députés qui
l'ont examiné et peut être remanié ce
projet de loi aux etats unis un couple
vivant dans l'état du colorado a utilisé
la génétique pour mettre au monde un
bébé éprouvette possédant des cellules
indispensable au sauvetage de sa soeur
âgée de 6 ans est atteint d'une maladie
du sang jusque là incurable celle ci
après une transplantation aurait
maintenant beaucoup de chance de survie
commentaires jean daniel flaysakier avec
jérôme soûlard et jean-pierre pasteur à
strasbourg
l'histoire du petit adam que rapporte la
presse américaine est étonnante
ce bébé a été conçu et sélectionné pour
être un donneur 100% compatible pour sa
soeur de 6 ans atteinte d'une maladie
sanguine mortel pour concevoir adam on a
stimulé la production les ovaires de
servir 15 ovocytes ont été recueillis au
lieu d'un lors d'une grossesse naturelle
féconder en laboratoire les quinze
embryons ont commencé leur développement
au troisième jour on a prélevé sur
chacun d'eux une cellule pour faire des
tests génétiques c'est ce que l'on
appelle le diagnostic préimplantatoire
sur les quinze embryons un seul s'est
avéré compatible c'est à dire conforme
au bureau chercher et a été réimplanté
dans l'utérus de la mère
à la naissance d'adam le 29 août dernier
on a prélevé du sang de son cordon
ombilical comme on le fait ici se sont
éteints sans riche en cellules
utilisable pour une greffe de moelle en
france depuis un an le diagnostic
préimplantatoire est également autorisée
mais uniquement pour des maladies
génétiques
face à un tel cas les spécialistes
auraient donc un vrai cas de conscience
d'un point de vue légal
enfin nous n'avons pas le droit les
mystiques
d'un point de vue technique c'est tout à
fait faisable et d'un point de vue
personnel vous aurez les positions
différents la mienne qui pas franchement
con je suis réticent parce que je crains
que ça ouvre à des dérives et que ça
permette à des couples de demander des
embryons selon la couleur et chaque lieu
où éventuellement pu simplement sexe de
l'enfant
on saura dans une semaine si la grève de
la petite molly a réussi si tel est le
cas les médecins estime à 90 % ses
chances de guérison
le port et l'aéroport d'ajaccio bloqué
aujourd'hui pas de bateau par avion les
employés de la chambre de commerce
d'ajaccio protestent contre la mise en
examen et l'emprisonnement de leur
président gilbert casanova pour
banqueroute et abus de biens sociaux les
sommes détournées sont évalués par la
justice à 32 millions de francs de
nouvelles manifestations de routiers
pourraient avoir lieu demain dans
plusieurs départements normands 10
côtes-d'armor frontière suisse et
frontière espagnole et routier espagnol
d'autre part en grève contre la hausse
du prix du carburant bloquer tout trafic
aujourd'hui entraînant ainsi
d'importantes perturbations économiques
comme le rapporte notre correspondant de
karine comazzi avec françoise maziou
narbonne
depuis ce matin la circulation des poids
lourds est interdite sur l'autoroute a9
en direction de l'espagne
pas de chance pour les camionneurs
européens arrivés à proximité de la
frontière et hier matin ils découvrent
le blocus et le terminus imposé ici au
sud de perpignan
notre problème c'est qu'on n'a rien à
manger est absolument rien pour ce sont
les et en plus la police ne nous dit
rien pour lui cette grève massive et
brutale et la réponse des transporteurs
espagnols à l'augmentation du gasoil à
130 p 7 soit 512 mo ou une gare nous
revendiquons la mise en place et à
alléger la fiscalité sur les carburants
et les combustibles
après tout les hausses exagérées que
nous avons subies nos entreprises ne
sont plus compétitives au marché
international de perpignan le blocus
routier réduit le négoce à seulement 4 %
du volume habituel commençant à porter
nos produits entre autres la clémentine
et les bien clair que là nous avons un
arrêt de campagne ce qui est toujours
préjudiciable aux intérêts des
professionnels
ce soir la croix rouge devrait fournir
de la nourriture aux routiers la levée
du blocus est prévu pour seulement
demain en fin d'après midi les militants
anti ogm de l'ariège qui avaient fauché
une parcelle de champs de colza
transgénique ont été condamnés des
peines symboliques de 8000 francs
d'amendé avec sursis décision une
semaine cruciale de fois pour des faits
commis en juin 99 la brigade central de
répression des contrefaçons de la police
judiciaire vient de démanteler un réseau
de fabrication et de vente de bronze
faussement attribuée à de grands
sculpteurs qu'une bourdelle bonheur
profond et rodin l'ensemble des bronzés
antiquités saisie est évaluée à 5
millions de francs 150 pièces ainsi
rassemblées par le police judiciaire qui
a interpellé quatre personnes
sport dernière épreuve pour les
médaillés français des jeux olympiques
de sydney l'épreuve de l' enthousiasme
de leurs supporteurs à leur retour en
france 200 athlètes sont arrivés ce
matin à l'aéroport de roissy et beaucoup
de bousculades au tour de jérôme thomas
roux l'a vu le médaillé de bronze boxer
font mouche
mais aussi autour de l'équipe de france
de basket ball pour des épéistes entre
autres et tous seront reçus le 6
novembre prochain à l'elysée par jacques
chirac
et puis une fête très particulière pour
le citoyen de bourgoin jallieu dans
l'isr le médaillé d'or boxeur mi-mouche
brahim asloum attendu comme un héros
dans sa ville le champion olympique qui
a été salué comme il se doit vous voyez
le reportage de benoît gadret et thiery
simonet brahim est de retour le gamin de
bourgoin retrouver les siens quelque 200
jeunes de son quartier venus
l'accueillir avec enthousiasme oui mais
parti de rien ça fait cinq ans alors
déroulé
c'est tout d'abord pour le quartier
mobile ça devra peut-être ambitions aux
jeunes au plus tard comme j'ai dit à
tout le monde si je peux en aide est
qu'un parmi tous à un seul je suis
garçon le plus complet du monde
les gels embrasse tous à l'aéroport le
champion a retrouvé ses parents une
famille de petits commerçants d'origine
algérienne il à la médaille pour la
france
les proches les amis tous portent des
t-shirts du sponsor de brain la
boucherie asloum un partenaire ici
incontournable c'est il a beau choix ce
moment c'est toute la famille mon père à
aller sans la libération à un long
cortège dans les rues de bourgoin le
fiston porté aux nues et pour ceux qui
ignorent encore son nom maman assure la
promotion dans la limousine de location
brahim veut devenir professionnel
aujourd'hui il a beaucoup appris
michel jonasz et ce soir à l'olympia
elle y restera jusqu'au 22 octobre avant
de se produire un peu partout en france
ces nouvelles chansons se rassembler
dans un album celui ci qui est intitulé
paul ouest le voici la primeur de ce
nouveau jonas su réserver à des
spectateurs bretons s'étaient à fougères
où frédéric bonnet patrick desmulie ont
rencontré le chanteur compositeur
m
on a beau s'appeler michel jonasz et
chanter de nouvelles chansons comme le
millénaire les petites salles de région
comme celle ci perdu en bretagne sont
tout aussi importantes que les autres
surtout si l'on prépare un nouveau
spectacle aussi sensuelle soit il
toujours spectacle est basé sur le conte
et si vous voulez sensuelle séduction
charme
c'est pour ça c'est bon ça c'est pas ça
je m'amuse toujours prêt je suis
heureuse l'odeur les les baffles les
instruments là quand je vois la batterie
je suis content quand je vois le piano
suis content j'ai passé un truc de mômes
à 53 ans michel jonasz s'offrent
l'olympia pour la quatrième fois et même
s'il nous propose un spectacle inédit
jonas aura toujours l'image du mister
swing des années 80 les cheveux
d'artistes en moins j'ai peur là
je meurs j'ai envie d'en aujourd'hui
jonas est fidèle à lui même ses
nouvelles chansons sont versés de
souvenirs d'émotions de souffrance qui
leur amène souvent à ses origines le
tsigane se réjouit en pleurant donc ça
peut être une joie tu pleurais aussi
parce qu'on est vivant ou quoi on
ressent des choses après 30 ans de
carrière jonas nous propose le
changement dans la continuité
michel jonasz à l'olympia je vous
rappelle l'actualité principale de cette
journée que nous avons longuement
développées notamment en compagnie de
leïla shahid déléguée palestinienne en
france
le cessez le feu n'a pas tenu entre
israéliens et palestiniens de nouveau
des morts et des blessés se soit encore
un palestinien tué à naplouse
yasser arafat ehud barak seront demain à
paris pour tenter de renouer un dialogue
très difficile mais il ya incertitude
sur leur rencontre qui ne serait pas
prévue mais peut-être aura-t-elle lieu à
moins qu'elle n'ait lieu à charm
el-cheikh où monsieur moubarak les
réunira à nouveau le dialogue semble
toujours très difficiles et les
affrontements continuent sur place ce
soir encore la météo dans quelques
instants avec sophie davant et puis
après le st
vous retrouverez laurent ruquier à 22h55
pour on a tout essayé puis à 1h15 du
matin le journal avec jean claude renaud
à 13h bien sûr ici même gérard holtz up
à demain 20h bonsoir merci
tout
non